this video was sponsored by amino apps
no amino is an ad where you can join
different communities and meet
like-minded people like yourselves no no
it's nothing like Pokemon go look it has
thousands of unique communities that
doesn't have anything to do with oh oh
oh to join a community you need to get
the app on either iOS or Android and
such what you're interested in
so as you can see I'm in the anime one
the even Guinean one and what up if you
can't find any community so you're lucky
you can even make your own
each community contains a news feed of
user-created content like blogs pause in
public chats that you can take part in
look see this guy's looking for a new
anime to watch he seems pretty friendly
so let's give him a little help a great
way to meet new people is just to follow
people you find interesting you can also
follow me on gig I can find out what I
think is my top grade a favorite anime
amino apps it's kind of like Pokemon go
it's nothing like Pokemon go don't meet
when you heard this before normal
teenage boy finds he has superpowers and
goes on the quest to save the world
loser nerd finds himself living with a
group of hot girls in the Playboy
Mansion and a group of dumps midgets who
don't do [ __ ] sits around getting an
audience bye-bye you know what this
doesn't look half bad
there are things in animate that we've
seen many times before but anime also
has this weird charm of being able to
make the most seemingly mundane idea to
the most off-the-cuff balls to the walls
concepts or an intellectual romp that
makes you question your own existence
where art can you see rock paper
scissors become an exhausting
intellectual battle of the mind a
gripping drama about garbage men in
space and a down to earth comedy where
Jesus and Buddha are budding roommates
in Tokyo bring so many possibilities
that there have been times when I've
looked at things in the real world and
thought you know what I think they're
space to create a narrative out this
that could make for an anime I'd watch
so here are five concepts based on
real-world things that I think could
work well in anime apologies if these
have been done before and I've missed
them so be sure to tell me if anything's
been done or at least done well we start
with something I'm sure a lot of you are
already familiar with video games and
while there have been plenty of anime
with video games in them has anything
been said about the craft that goes into
making them I'm on the line
me like my name my career if this if
this fails I don't think I'll workin
games again when you think of anime and
video games what do you think I mean we
have people playing video games people
getting trapped into video games people
get entrapped in video games people
getting trapped in video games you were
getting trapped in video games but the
closest thing we get an anime to making
video games is a school club attempting
to put together a simple demo or the
flawless logic we see behind a group of
dudes creating a hentai game why do you
wanna sleep I gotta fall off of you how
does class equal [ __ ] I get to see an
anime that follows the entire
development cycle of a video game which
I think could be very interesting from
the evolution of the initial concept to
the work done to bring that idea to life
to the extensive thought process that
goes into level design to the explosive
marketing before release there's plenty
of material could be covered to make an
entertaining story and if there's one
country that knows about making video
games its Japan maybe you can argue that
my natural engineering instincts as well
it's driving me to think that such a
concept it'd make for an interesting
show but things like indie game the
movie showed us that you can easily
create a narrative that we care for
about the people behind the video games
and shirobako
already proved that seeing the
development cycle of a medium can not
only be intriguing but also educational
too I know some people are waiting to
just ask me hey what about new game
coming out this season to which I say
yeah that's an anime about game
development like k-on was an anime about
music guys music you know what maybe all
I'm asking for PA was to do sure ibaka
again just with game development this
time yeah that pretty much sums it up is
that too much to ask
great now while anime can be a platform
for the most out of the world concepts
there are many shows that hits much
closer to home when telling the more
delicate human stories but there is one
thing that I haven't really seen a show
do yet
we've all seen it a million times before
love triangles left pence corns love
dodecahedron romance and anime always
seems to boil down to a group of friends
or romantically interested in each other
like we're repeating the same season of
friends over and over except no one ever
likes the person they're supposed to
like and let's of course you from school
days and in which case you're just a
walking sex Terminator sleeping with
anything closely resembling a vagina in
any case the rama's normally ends when
the final couple finally realized that
they like each other and kiss or you
know hold hands or some [ __ ] oh my god
she's holding my hand going beyond that
you have a few anime that portrays the
whole relationship of a couple and the
struggles that they go through but what
I haven't seen is an anime that
resembles how most people's romantic
lives actually go only the lucky few
find the love of their lives on the
first try and most people go through
multiple relationships before finding
the one that want to end up with not
every relationship you go through or be
a happy one you get her you struggle
through and sometimes people change
along the way but it's a journey that
people take through life and it makes
finding the actual person you want to
stay with that much sweeter you don't
always need a love hex to go in to
create suitable drama as a lot of
people's lives actually have enough
drama in them if we follow them for long
enough we've seen us in film but for
some reason I just cannot connect to
Hollywood romances the same way I can
with anime romances because you know
they're [ __ ] 3d people and how the
[ __ ] am I supposed to relate to that the
closest thing I've seen is something
like five centimeters per second but
that was less of a happy romance and
more of an outlook on how distance can
grow between people overall romance in
anime at the moment is very touching and
sweet but if they were able to tell a
story of someone's entire romantic life
from beginning to end that could be a
fresh concept full of genre moving on
from the realism in life I want to talk
about something that has mystified me
ever since I was a kid
something would wonder I'm mystique that
you can almost say was magical
walking on water
I have a small confession to make back
when I was a shiny eyed little kid
worrying about my next math class in
school I went through a phase when I was
obsessed with magic and magicians from
the gritty Street magic displayed by
David Blaine to the grand event staged
by David Copperfield magic was well
magical for me I would watch countless
clips of different magicians and marvel
at the spectacle while pondering for
days about how certain tricks were done
and of course being the curious bugger
that I was I would have to ruin magic
for myself by researching the secret
behind every magic trick except it
didn't ruin it for me instead of turning
me off magic I was actually amazed by
the amount of background work and skill
needed to perform even the simplest of
tricks while magic itself is not a new
concept to anime at all with wizards and
witches everywhere firing laser beams
out to their nipples in the abundance of
fantasy shows out there actual
real-world magicians are something I've
never seen before but why would they I
mean what's the point of making a show
about magic when you can literally draw
any event you want right well behind the
scenes there is so much work a magician
has to put into it if they want to be
great the councilís hours needed to
practice sleight of hand the art of
misdirection the brilliantly designed
stage props used to bend the imagination
and of course the showmanship that all
leads to the satisfaction of pulling off
a great show it's the entire craft and
there have already been stories told in
movies about the lighter and darker side
of how dedicated you have to be towards
it and anime is one of the only mediums
I know that can make explaining these
elements into an interesting scene like
they do when explaining the simplest
move in any sports anime for example I
believe all these elements could blend
together to make an interesting story
about the journey any magician takes the
work they have to put in or maybe even
the sacrifices they need to make to be
great and if there's any medium that
could tell this story its anime but
enough about learning how things work
this is anime not the engineering
channel we want grand stories in
ever-expanding worlds with big cast of
characters that we actually care about
isn't there something we can do there
well you know what Hollywood may have
the answer
if there is one hot concept in Hollywood
nowadays it's a shared universe ever
since the record-breaking Avengers put
together the unlikely crew of Bill Gates
captain freedom a supermodel a brick
[ __ ] Shakespeare and Hawkeye the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has become one
of the biggest franchises in the world
and now with every studio rushing to
find a next big shared universe I
couldn't help but be curious to see if
anime could do something similar while
we see the odd cameo here and there and
some series that take place in the same
universe like the nah reverse or Tsubasa
chronicles there hasn't really been a
story where a group of individual
stories collide together to create
something much grander and it's
something that could be easily achieved
something like bark a no-show - you
don't even need a main character to
carry a show just a group of interesting
characters colliding with one another
now imagine this just on a much grander
scale one parts of anime that I think
could really benefit from this would be
the shown in battle genre what would
happen if characters like Luffy Naruto
and Ichiko were active part of the same
universe and the paths actually led them
together towards something much bigger
or what about a group of characters who
come together in a battle royale type
tournament like we see in the beta
franchise see I actually got this idea
thinking about the dilemma every fate
adaptation goes through what's that
dilemma you ask well when you throw
together a huge cast of characters all
with varying backstories and motivation
how can you possibly portray all this
information without boring the audience
to death of hours of exposition it's
something that works in the visual
novels as they have hours and hours of
play time to be able to delve into
detail but in the limited run time of an
anime this isn't so possible so what if
we show the individual backstories of
the servants before they take part in
the Holy Grail war it would make
character interactions much more
interesting and the impact of every
major event hits much harder since we've
already invested in the characters anime
especially the shown in genre I think
could do wonders with this concept and I
for one would love to see it right now
with one spot left there has been one
sub-genre of anime that has largely
grown in popularity in recent years due
to some breakout hits and they got me
thinking about how it could also be
applied to something else that surge in
popularity recently as we once more
revisit the world of video gaming
the biggest tournament of the year he's
up there some of the best in the world
it's gonna be interesting these guys
devote everything to this it's right
here right now they have waited all year
for this moment so guys let's get this
started
if you've been living under a rock these
past few years here's one irrefutable
fact that's been cropped up which a
generation of parents have tried to
convince you is stupid people really
like watching video games whether it be
about one guy in his room freaking his
ass off or teams of people competing to
be the best in the world or thousands of
people screaming at a massive LAN party
if there's one concept I think is just a
ski to be made it's in eSports those you
unacquainted with the term esports is a
term hust labeled form of sport that
describes competitive and professional
video gaming and is one of the fastest
growing sports in recent times millions
of people around the world are tuning in
to competitive gaming because well it's
exciting it's really exciting look this
guy is so excited he sounds like a horny
boyfriend trying to convince his
girlfriend for sex
with the advent of sword art online and
his whole trend of making anime about
videogames
along with Sports anime being hyped as
they are and eSports anime would fit
pretty perfectly into what we've seen
anime can do well but before everyone
goes off mailing production i.g to start
making the next career kono League of
Legends
let's look into why this have actually
worked so well as with any traditional
sports one of the reasons it's so
compelling to follow is because if you
follow it enough and narrative forms
there are underdog stories rivalries
superstar protagonists and villains
unknown newbies rising through the ranks
and real-life events that seemingly
could only be scripted by the gods are
littered everywhere in sports and
competitive gaming is no different it's
not hard to make a narrative out of a
sport because by and large narrative is
already there the only difference is
that this will be based on a fictional
game and eSports athletes are so young
we wouldn't even need to put this in a
high school setting where we need to win
for the samp eyes guys the samp eyes
they're gonna be graduating next year
and this is the last time we can play
with them as every simpler than it never
becomes irrelevant in the final match
anyway but the one thing that would
separates eSports from your traditional
sports anime is how I can create a sport
with its own set of rules even though
every genre has the same set of goals
shooting someone punching someone
destroying the enemy base the rules of
how you achieve these goals is entirely
up to the author's discretion different
games can have different characters
different tactics different abilities
and all these can be easily exploited
we've already seen how fictional game
rules can be stretched and exploited in
shows like law horizon and no gamer life
which was really entertaining to watch
and a fictional eSport would be the
perfect platform for something like this
to shine as an infinite amount of
possible tactics could be used not to
mention the current trend in competitive
game too often patch and change around
their games so the tactics would always
be constantly evolving and best of all
this can all actually be explained to
the audience in depth so they can
understand instead of you know getting
confused as to why the Korean sound like
they're having multiple orgasms every
time there's a teamfight an anime like
this would not only be high-pitched [ __ ]
but could also be intellectually
stimulating at the same time that all in
all I think it would be an absolutely
entertaining watch if done right and
that was pretty much everything I had in
mind let's not forget that concepts
don't mean everything there have been
plenty of interesting concepts that were
let down by shoddy execution and
concepts we've seen many times before
that have been great because of great
writing and characters we gotcha care
about that said though I'm sure you guys
can think of loads more things that
could be
dressed into as one thing we love about
this medium is the possibilities are
just seemingly endless hey guys hope you
enjoyed the video thank you very much
this month's - shameless Lao can Vidal
is JP joseline and everyone else on
patreon for supporting me and also thank
you very much your Mina for sponsoring
this episode and if you want to check
out more of my stuff just click on the
links here but anyway that's it for me
not too many updates this time I've been
gig up and I'll see you all next time